hey bonus video today but before it
begins I just want to say I'm gonna be
streaming tomorrow at twitch TV slash
neckla it's gonna be probably the best
stream of your life edgar is so excited
as well he might even be there it's
gonna be really fun we have a ton of
cool stuff we're gonna do just don't
miss it you don't want to miss it what
are you doing don't miss it
thank you listen to Marcia now I enjoyed
the video
what is happening family friendly Felix
here we're gonna play paradigmatic card
paradigm I played this game when he had
the Kickstarter I loved I loved it I
loved it a lot I thought it was so
interesting I've been following the guys
development on Twitter it's super
interesting I'm very excited to play it
it doesn't happen everyday that I'm
actually excited to play the game that
I'm playing how about yeah choose your
difficulty oh god how did this happen
I just okay I I think I'll go with metal
[Music]
okay okay let's go
oh if I remote crackly there should be a
movie playing is your child a failure
yes do you make it rain on a regular
basis I do I do
[Music]
only depended on your child's expensive
taste in [ __ ] coffee rapid ink is
your child just an [ __ ] yes I mean my
dog is here at duper genetics we have
the solution
too bad prodigy child a fully
customizable child of your dreams the
process is very simple we gather your
broken dreams we combine it with our
cutting-edge genetic sequencing
technology okay and finally our secret
sauce and then your prodigy child is
born
relieve your child success to chance
well what do I do with the failures how
did your child in anything such as
scientist body bill oh wow wizard and
cat you know that you really want to
risk the embarrassment by a prodigy
child today you won't regret
honestly I'm calling right now I can't
oh god where did it go wrong time to put
on some pizzas he's gonna put on beats
okay all right so here we are I'm so
bored it's the tumor talking to the
tumor is talking to me okay so here we
are in paradigm like how we moose nice
we have the John 303,000 doesn't seem to
be working all right let's look at that
they are LPS we have get rich or die of
natural causes
baby I love you but I'm a t-rex okay
Pluto if only I was still if you were a
square I love all your four sides that's
a bit too sexual for my taste
all right we have an adapter here I
could that we could pick up this could
be if only people could a dip like this
adapter robot human marriage would be
such a big issue if Jesus I'd forgotten
how to use my pockets again really great
tutorials voice okay so let me have
inventory all right hey it's an adapter
use on the John needs some sort of
adapter first oh my god okay so we can
do that that's easy
aren't you feeling super smart hey how
about that I can solve already played
okay all right I want to make some fat
that face is so terrifying what is wrong
with it I don't know why it looks here
doesn't have a nose sorry I just
realized okay so we need to [ __ ] all
right this might be a tricky don't panic
that computer says derp on it why is her
cereal everywhere okay a floppy disk we
need a floppy disk
there's whatever let's let's pick it up
wherever it is let's pick it up okay we
can't pick it up we can't what is this
then pick up never okay fine we'll just
go to the Red Room okay let's not go to
the relieve yet besides [ __ ] okay we
need that we need the floppy disk all
right are there pants up here those are
my 60 pins for it okay forget I asked
forget I asked okay floppy disk maybe
here [ __ ] I need to get something
all right we have down ours a diary some
kind of Russian maybe we need to get one
of these yeah it's got to be this one
pick up yes I'm so smart how do we play
it let's just let's just give it to him
here you go buddy yeah I told you is
this option oh my god this guy's cringer
than me what the [ __ ]
what is this how do they make that
you gotta get the floppy disk got it
okay we got to see dog outside great
let's go
this is super fun I'm really enjoying
this meanwhile Oh God
I think our convenient plot develops yes
the villain yes I want I want you to
bring me paradigm is that Trump yes we
need
oh hey
sometimes I hate you that's his father
satiable urge for candy turned me into
this monstrosity that is a beat that is
a beat that spits bead I remember that
as cool ash two guys a German all the
sudden miniature unicorns fighting
warrior pugs why miniature unicorn
fighting flying pug Sparrow station I
mean by public vote is never a good idea
or is it the best what is this talk to
yellow deactivated John three thousand
good okay alright let's talk to the
beats alright drop me that fat beat sees
that's yeah I was pretty good um alright
we need to know what about space cadet
know much about this biscuit hmm I know
is that he is the local drug addict gold
or acne 47 years old uncomfortably
apparent fetish for boxes I guess that's
him I don't know much about him really
except he keeps asking for drugs in
exchange for his boxes also also [ __ ]
snow thus a family-friendly goddamnit
[Music]
fine look away if I wasn't the drug in
this I would probably consider it no no
no not again [ __ ] alright so we got to
find him a Matt right
I don't know how look I love our mail
books yeah I guess I'll put the delay in
three wait wait what
there was a mail box off a [ __ ] stop god
damn it there is another yeah there is a
postcard in here with a bottle of vodka
really she is vodka the only look at the
guaranty sixty percent of your daily
nutritional me what is it alcohol and
the 50% chance of unemployment plus
postcard MEPs is to press the letter M
for you okay alright we're going there
we go in there excellent alright well
looks like we'll go there and the next
episode if you enjoyed watching leave it
like even if you wanted me to play more
I would love to do that so show your
support and I really appreciate this
great way for me to know whether you
guys want more of this or not and that's
all for me for now thank you so much for
watching and as always stay awesome bros